une main jaune et cette phrase touche
pas à mon pote
voici le symbole de sos racisme quelques
mois après la création de cette
association le 15 octobre 1984 le slogan
décliné en badge devient l'emblème de la
lutte contre le racisme
son créateur le journaliste didier
françois alias rocky membres de sos
racisme expliqué alors son origine
l'allemand ouverte si tu veux ce d'amour
s'est produit tôt parce qu'il faut dire
arrêtez arrêtez cette stupide
c'est aussi un geste de conciliation
gestes tendres 2001 tendu une main
tendue à l'heure où les crimes racistes
se multiplient en france
grâce à ce slogan l'un des fondateurs de
sos racisme harlem désir espérait
envoyer un message fort à toute la
jeunesse française le racisme
à force de discours de haine à force de
discours anti immigrés a fini par
imprégner y compris la jeunesse mais
c'est peut-être pour ça que nous avons
eues et nous avons ressenti la nécessité
de lancer une initiative est de dire
halte là ça suffit
un appel entendu par de nombreux jeunes
le badge devient même pour certains un
emblème fédérateur dans les lycées la
main jaune se vend à la sortie des cours
et fait même émergé des discussions au
sein des classes
bon bah moi j'ai ressenti la nécessité
de le porter puisque je suis victime du
racisme
je suis fier de porter premier match que
j'ai achetée était jaune jeu justement
choisi jaune parce qu'on le voyait bien
pour bien montrer justement aux gens de
nombreuses célébrités prennent aussi
part au mouvement coluche en faisait
partie et afficher fièrement ses badges
ici
l'humoriste intervenait au lycée henri
iv à paris je crois que les que les
français sont pas vraiment raciste je
crois que il ya une génération de mecs
qui sont
un petit peu encombré par des
considérations coloniale passée
l'association sos racisme organisée
autour de son slogan rencontre un succès
fulgurant en juin 1985 huit mois après
sa création plus d'un million et demi de
badges et t vendu un bilan dont se
félicitait harlem désir au concert des
potes sur la place de la concorde
on peut dire que rien ne nous a été
épargné
toutes les embûches tous les bruits
toutes les poses informations eu cours
et bien pourtant vous êtes là vous êtes
venu parce que vous le savez ce
mouvement n'appartient à personne parce
qu'il n'appartient qu'à vous à vous d'y
porter le badge touche pas à mon pote
fait encore aujourd'hui partie des
emblèmes de la lutte contre le racisme
[Musique]
où